So switching over to Android Studio,
I've created a little app to demonstrate
extracting a pallet from an image.
The first thing we need to do in our
apps file is add the support library for
a pallet as a dependency.
So after we receive an image
resource identifier for
an image, we can load it into our
view and convert it into a bitmap
that the palette will use to
generate the color swatches.
Alternatively, If we've taken a photo,
we'll receive a bitmap from
the camera without the need for
that conversion step.
These color swatches fall into two
different areas, either vibrant or
a muted color.
The type and
number of swatches is dependent
on the composition of your image.
And how much of it is
in a certain color and
how that color contrast to
other colors in the image.
If you want to read more about that,
you can check the instructors notes for
a link to the java docs,
for the palette library.
So right here in this code, I take
the palette and I'm looking through
all of the different swatches to see if
they exist before returning a hash mat.
So let's check it out on a device.
If we hit this floating action
button and pick an image,
let's pick something from our
Android Nanodegree kick off.
We can see that it's
created a palette for us.
Now, one of the interesting colors here
is this vibrant color from
these Android stickers.
When I click the item it shows
us how many pixels in the image
were from that color.
Next, Roman is going to talk
to you about typography.